depuis quelques jours des djiby sont
fabriqués à nevers un engin hybride
entre scooters électriques vélos et
trottinettes 80 km d'autonomie pour une
mobilité pratique et ludique
j'ai voulu avoir un véhicule confortable
avec une bonne une bonne position
ergonomique avec un centre de gravité
sans siège sans sel sans
fabriquée au québec il est assemblé dans
un esat de nevers pour le marché
européen
15 exemplaires pour la phase de test une
vingtaine par mois à venir pour
l'établissement c'est une fierté d'avoir
été retenue satisfait et c'est une
reconnaissance des savoir faire que nous
avons aujourd'hui je dirais pas qu'on
est déjà rodé mais voilà au bout d'une
journée de montage on a
on à cerner les problématiques avoir de
façon plus précise
mais pourquoi avoir choisi nevers pour
l'entreprise le contexte autour de la
mobilité y est favorable
proximité du pôle économique de magny
cours et de l'institut supérieur de
l'automobile et des transports
le tout avec des avantages géographiques
nevers a quand même une position qui est
très central que ce soit au niveau de la
france mais aussi au niveau de l'europe
de l'ouest et
ce qu'on veut c'est qu'ici ça devienne
aussi notre hub maintenance et ub
logistiques donc pour le dispatch des
des produits finis vers les différents
pays que l'on vise en ordre de l'ouest
le partenariat s'est noué lors d'un
déplacement d'élus de l'agglomération au
québec
une bonne nouvelle pour nevers car à
long terme les perspectives pour et
évoluer la société a été clair au départ
c'était pas pour voilà posé un siège
social une usine et puis crée tant
d'emplois si elle monte en puissance y
aura forcément des besoins d'emploi pour
l'assemblage vers l'implantation de la
société québécoise suscite aussi
désespoir que d'autres entreprises
suivent cet exemple pour relancer
l'activité du territoire et faire de
nevers un pôle autour des nouvelles
mobilités